ich bin so froh wenn wir das wieder
lohnt sind es war ein fehler überhaupt
auf die idee zu kommen
[Musik]
etwas gekauft war nur ein video jahr
hätten ursprünglich auf jeden fall sie
haben gerade montag abend und heute in
ein paket angekommen
[Musik]
das ding jetzt wohl die leute ja gar
nicht soviel verraten jetzt ein paket
einkommen erstmal keine sorge das ist
natürlich kein echtes baby aber ich bin
alex und ich habe wieder eine richtige
idee und habe ich irgendwo im abo tv
gewinnt die leute sein baby wirklich ein
voll funktionsfähiges computer baby was
komplett dem echten baby entspricht
einfach zu heiß um für jüngere mütter
oder wurst zu üben und ich habe es auch
in dem stellt aber ein richtig finden so
witzig
deswegen fällt mal auf wir haben hier
ein baby ich hab schon ausgepackt die
anderen sachen nicht aber das ist weil
wir dem namen geben können
nun möchte das hier ist jetzt der kevin
das ist unser voll funktionsfähige der
name ist natürlich nur bitten
unterhaltungstechnik gedachte nennt ihn
jetzt einfach mal ein junger ich habe
sie nicht überrascht und weil es auf
jeden fall ein junger heißt kevin bauen
und ich habe mir gedacht ich schätze mal
ob ich wirklich bereit wäre ein kind
also nicht hinbekommen ob ich wirklich
bereit wäre vater zu werden weil dieses
ding das kann ich nicht abstellen
das holz schon heute bei 13 uhr
35 tagen oder diesen tage keine ahnung
und ich begleite euch einfach mal ein
bisschen und ich bin mal gespannt ob das
was wir oder auch mehr das sorgt er geht
als ich aus dem fenster werfen
natürlich würde ich mich niemals zu
behandeln arbeitet ist jetzt nur ein
computerproblem die halt schreibt wenn
man die auf dem kopf steht anscheinend
ist hier noch ein paar extras lassen
sich dass ich wieder so lange lagen
anfangs heftig über qet wurden dazu habe
ich noch bekommen ein fläschchen es
praktisch geplatzt
guck mal neue unterhosen für dich geld
noch gewinnt das keine windel hat ist
einfach da hilfen knopf wenn es auf
toilette macht dass van der vaart
allernächsten zensoren
das heißt also wieder verkennt dass sie
in die hände gewechselt hat jetzt das
schlösschen die sachen die bereits
magath ja auch und hier nochmal ein
strampelanzug genau in deiner größte
auch leute die haben ja zeit wo ich
jetzt sagen ich hab keinen bock dass du
hast dir aller macht issinghoff ich ich
ich kümmere mich erst morgen und ich ein
paar sekunden später doch nicht mit dem
schlafengehen
entwickler ohne witz detail wird mit
leuchtend letzten nerv rauben
so leute was geht eher verschlafen
ich habe das baby mir gedacht komm legt
es in ein zimmer wenn es frei sich darum
aber ich habe eigentlich auch darauf
dass es einfach leitet und ich hoffe mal
das funktioniert das soll ja auch mal
schlafen frau liegt es einfach hier ich
habe ich im schlaf legen und ende
reichlich nacht oder halt nicht also bis
später 30 28 nach 3 uhr 46 und ich hab
grad 20 minuten möchte um kümmert es ist
ein leises und ich bin mega müde und
muss auch morgen er früher aufstehen
jetzt ist es wieder leise und ich legte
jetzt einfach wieder ganz normal gut
noch etwas geht leute wären es gerade
dienstag ich bin ja von der uni nach
hause kommen und bin echt müde aber wie
man hört schlafen kann ich erst mal
leider nicht und wahrscheinlich schon
den ganzen morgen
fritz nicht möglich zu sagen ich bin
[Musik]
einfach nur schlafen durch die keinen
vergleich bringt der kinder sei die
müssen wir vermitteln wahlleiter fest
einfach nur ich weitermachen soll es ist
halt doch einfach mal bitte auf woran
ich das hätte sagt peter plätzen nichts
weiß nicht annahmen sind ohne spaß ich
mal etwa des namens helfer geklappt
das lag am namensschild leute der hitze
ganze kevin weil du dass du dran gemacht
hat ich geht um etwas schönes fashion
hier jetzt fix noch ein kleines lied zum
einschlafen
nur der kevin den ganzen tag schreiter
schon heftig ich wette es gleich wieder
los ein paar sekunden später haben sich
die hände von dem 6
oh ich würde das geschützte komisch
[Applaus]
juni gemacht du kannst du auch nur zum
spaß daran und ich habe auch die windel
eineinhalb wichtig so leute vielleicht
ein kleines update jetzt gerade ist
mittwoch das kam montag an um 13 uhr
glaube ich und es ist das wirklich
durchgehend jetzt gerade nicht das
scheint sogar macht ich bin heute nacht
in decke eingewickelt mir der haft
kontakt ging und dann hat man sich so
gehört aber jetzt bin ich gerade merkt
man auf die idee gekommen die winde zu
wechseln und mein mitbewohner richtig
gern fällt schon auf wandel seine
arbeiten machen muss willst du beim
echten baby auch gefragt sein
[Applaus]
bis später leute ist nur ein kurzes
update wie man sieht ich habe letzte
nacht nicht so viel geschlafen
zweimal bin ich wach geworden weil es
angefangen zu schreien auch mit mir das
ding ist ganz einfach wir haben das 2
hier oben und wir schlafen unten nur das
treibt so laut man hat das sogar man
wird einfach davon wach ich weiß nicht
was da für lautsprecher drin ist
arbeitete ich krank und ich bin froh
dass es jetzt klappt man nicht ehrlich
das konto sinnvoll wenn ein echtes baby
wirklich so ist dann das weckt an jede
mutter oder einfach mal so sagen ja
leute also gratis donnerstag wie schon
gesagt montag kam es an
kurz aktiviert und es geht auch bis zum
morgen mittag und ich bin so froh wenn
das ding einfach wieder aus ist und mir
nicht mehr auf die nerven gehen kann ja
ein paar sekunden später kein halt für
mein video und weiter heißt es weiter
vereinfacht ich bin so froh wenn wir das
wieder los sind es war ein flieger
überhaupt auf die idee zu kommen so ein
experiment zu machen weil ich kann es
sich noch mal 100 das wieder an
genau deswegen meldet heute abend hier
entdecken entwickeln und einfach
weiterlaufen und dann morgen doch mein
kleines diese nie verpassen
die zeit dieses experiment da und wie du
mich bin das sind zwei anzeigen aber das
hat weiter sechs mal
[Musik]
leute was geht ab ich weiß nicht ob man
es mehr anbieter aber ich bin echt nicht
mehr so gut dabei wäre donnerstagabend
und ich hab das ding ausgestellt ich
habe irgendwie kontakt aufgenommen zur
vermittlung und hab irgendwie himmel
auch vom knopf drücken müssen und jetzt
nicht das ding auf und fährt es lagen
aber das team ist auf den sack
also echt volk respekt an jede mutter so
das musste einfach mal sein weil wenn
babys so vielen wie der hier alter er
hat wirklich der hat einst nichts
anderes gemacht aus rein
ich weiß gar nicht wie lange dieser akku
drin halten kann weil er ein nicht
komplett die ganze zeit aktive und
schreibrechte vielleicht irgendwas sagen
zu meinen zuschauern alles klar danke
das war's mit dem video ihr könnt ihr
meinen kommentar sein was sich eventuell
noch ein experiment machen soll schreibt
in die kommentare ich würde sagen bei
diesem video
es war ja viel aufwand sind 15.000
leicht bestimmt irgendwie drin oder
sagen wir 13.000 keine ahnung und ja
mehr will ich nicht sagen ich bin froh
dass jetzt überstanden habt hier die
weitab in sound - closing im dot com
und wir sehen uns dann am sonntag wieder
sondern gibt's neues video um 14 uhr weg
haut rein
ich wünsche euch noch schön abend oder
was auch immer
und heute euch niemals so ein test baby
befreit euch nur komplett eure nerven